oh it's the holidays we'd love to spread
a little cheer to those who are so
deserving and when we heard from members
of the lower east side girls club that
they wanted to do something special for
their program manager we wanted to help
so amaryllis jimenez has been with the
organization for over a decade and she's
dedicated herself to setting young women
up for a successful future
and normally she's in charge of
decorating the girls club but this year
we wanted to you know give her a little
help and support so we sent
brilliant designer michael welch out on
a special ambush decoration mission
check this out
drew's elf is here for a very special
decorating mission i'm outside of the
lower east side girls club and i am
going to give a surprise to amaryllis
amaryllis is always here decorating and
crafting and making everything look
special for the girls she's even been
known to go into her own pocket to help
pay for decor i'm going to go in and
surprise her with the best christmas
makeover that she's ever seen before
amarillo's is absolutely deserving
because she's the most supportive
creative wonderful spirited member of
our staff she's our program manager for
the creative studios which means she
works hands-on with our members every
day doing creative projects amaryllis is
amazing she's very creative she cares
for everyone she reaches out to everyone
amarelus deserves this honor because
she's very caring she loves us all and
she thinks about others a lot we love
amaryllis
and she's amazing amorous is amazing
that's all we could say amaryllis is
working so hard all year round but
especially during the holidays making
the girls club feel special and we're
excited to celebrate her and give her
something special this holiday season
drew and i want to give a very special
thank you to christmas tree shops for
providing all of this beautiful holiday
decor
a simple and easy way to create decor is
with ornaments all you do is take old
ornaments that you don't use or even
ones that are broken and you can place
them inside of a box or your favorite
bowl they go right onto your coffee
table and it's going to be an amazing
centerpiece
when you have a large wall the main
thing is to create a backdrop what you
want to do is incorporate several trees
at varying heights then you can
embellish with all of your smaller
decorations who doesn't love an
oversized bear
all right team we're coming up on one
hour i think amaryllis is almost here
amaryllis is on her way in right now
[Music]
oh my god this is so beautiful
wow hey amarilla's come on over
it's totally different right well it is
wow i love it this is amazing wow
i heard that you do a lot for the lower
east side girls club it's so beautiful
this is a huge gift from drew and i
because you give so much to these girls
in this community wow
this is good
i love it today when the girls get into
the door they're gonna be so surprised
and so happy thank you so much
[Applause]
santa's incredible elf designer mikael
welch is here
true crew member and my design partner
in crime um mikael how many magazines
are you in this month like house
beautiful veranda l decor everything i
don't know santa came early for me so i
got lucky you are everywhere and i would
love to know as the expert designer that
you are what is your advice for anyone
who's decorating a big space but wants
to do it with a budget friendly approach
okay so here's the thing i like to get
sneaky and take old shipping boxes and
wrap them with gift wrapping paper
because when you do that it embellishes
the tree just make sure your like guests
know that those are like dummy boxes but
it'll totally beef everything up and
you're good to go or in my kids cases a
decoration not for you
they'll be very mad
they'll appreciate it later um okay now
i know you made amaryllis and everyone
at the lower east side girls club very
happy
and um emeralds is here hello
[Applause]
how are you today
so happy
what makes this year
and with what mikael did
different than other years what is your
normal approach and what's this year
been like
well
this year it was perfect
it was amazing everybody loved it
i don't know what to say but it was
super nice um
i want to cry right now because
when i saw that all the girls coming
they were like what happened like this
is so beautiful and
wow
thank you thank you you are the best
thank you exactly how we feel thank you
for letting us into your place to your
journey
to these girls and thank you for macau
because
you are so amazing at what you do
we're healing people through design so
that's the great part about it well
you're a beautiful person and i'm so
glad that it worked for you thank you so
much and to continue
all of the amazing programs that you
offer at the lower east side girls club
we're gonna gift you with the thousand
dollar donation just please make sure
that you have a little bit of what you
need for this holiday season and a
special thank you to christmas tree
shops for helping make this holiday
dream a reality and enabling mikael to
do what he needs to do we want to wish
everyone at the lower east side girls
club a very happy holiday amaryllis
thank you thanks for letting us do this
[Music]